A shaken
campus, uniting in grief
The University of Virginia
mourning three football players.
Two other students were injured
after a shooting rocked the school.
The shootings
occurred on a bus full of students
turning from a field trip.
Three of the victims did not survive
Gunshots rang out Sunday night.
An intense manhunt
in and around
Charlottesville for the suspect followed.
Pardon me.
In the middle of a press conference,
the news
everyone on campus was hoping for
Thank you, Captain.
We just received information.
The suspect is in custody.
Police have identified the suspect
as university
of Virginia student
Christopher Darnell Jones Jr.
The 22 year old was a freshman on the UVA
football team in 2018 but did not play in
any games.
Police said Jones was arrested
about 75 miles outside
the Charlottesville campus.
The university identified the victims
as Devin
Chandler, Lavelle Davis Jr
and Deshawn Perry.
All current football players.
Officials did not identify
the two additional students
injured in the incident.
The UVA football team
expressed its heartbreak
in a tweet saying, quote,
There are no words to describe
this tremendous loss
to our UVA football family.
Their coach
calling them
incredible young men
with huge aspirations
and extremely bright futures.
A sentiment of sorrow
echoed by the University
of Virginia's president.
My heart is broken for the victims
and their families
and for all those
who knew and loved them.
The suspect's
father told CNN affiliate W TVR.
He is heartbroken and in disbelief.
I don't I don't know what to say
except I'm
sorry on his behalf.
And I apologize
Police said the suspect had come
to the UVA
police department's attention before.
They said
Jones had a prior incident
involving a concealed weapon
in 20, 21
outside the city of Charlottesville.
UVA's Judicial Council took over the case
and the results are pending.
According to police
During a press conference yesterday.
UVA's police chief
also said that in September,
a non
student claimed Jones
had made a comment
about possessing a gun.
But to the knowledge of the police,
that person
never actually saw the gun in question.
The victim's families
and the suspect's father shaken
now hoping for answers.
What happened?
Why did had to get this far?
He could have called me.